ISRAELI JETS STRUCK AT IRANIAN
TARGETS INSIDE OF SYRIA.
>> Bret: THANK YOU.
PRESIDENT TRUMP APPEARS TO HAVE
A BANNER DAY AFTER ONE OF THE
CLOSEST ALLIES LAID OUT EVIDENCE
AND WHAT THE PRESIDENT HAS BEEN
SAYS ABOUT THE NUCLEAR DEAL.
AND ANOTHER LEADER SAID
PRESIDENT TRUMP SHOULD GET THE
NOBEL PEACE PRIZE FOR THE
DEVELOPMENTS IN NORTH AND SOUTH
KOREA.
>> Reporter: PRESIDENT TRUMP
INSISTED THAT IRAN IS NOT IN
COMPLIANCE WITH THE JCBA.
AND THAT IS WHY DESPITE LOUD
CRITICISM HE DECERTIFIED IT AND
DESPITE THE U.N. AND JAMES
MATTIS CERTIFIED THAT IRAN IS IN
COMPLIANCE.
SPEAK NOTHING THE ROSE GARDEN
WITH THE PRESIDENT OF NIGERIA
PRESIDENT TRUMP SAID THE
EVIDENCE REVEALED BY ISRAEL.
I TOLD YOU SO.
IT IS NOT ACCEPTABLE.
THEY ARE NOT SITTING BACK IDLY.
AND THEY SET OFF MISSILES FOR
TELEVISION PURPOSES.
I DON'T KNOWING SO.
>> Reporter: PRESIDENT TRUMP
FACES A MAY 12TH WAIVER.
>> I AM NOT TELLING YOU WHAT I
AM DOING.
PEOPLE THINK THEY KNOW.
WE'LL MAKE A DECISION.
>> Reporter: PRESIDENT TRUMP
INDICATED HE MAY BE OPEN TO
LEAVING THE NUCLEAR DEAL IN
PLACE IF THE U.S. AND ALLIES CAN
ADDRESS IRAN'S LONG- TERM
BALLISTIC PROGRAM AND
DESTABILIZING BEHAVIOR.
>> WE'LL SEE WHAT HAPPENS.
AND I THINK IF ANYTHING WHAT
HAPPEN TODAY AND WHAT WE HAVE
LEARNED HAS REALLY SHOWN THAT I
WAS 100 PERCENT RIGHT.
>> Reporter: ON NORTH KOREA.
TWEETING THAT HIS PENDING SUMMIT
WITH KIM JONG-UN SHOULD TAKE
PLACE IN THE DMZ AT THE SAME
LOCATION THAT THE KIM AND THE
SOUTH KOREA PRESIDENT MET.
>> IT IS AN INTERESTING THOUGHT.
SOME PEOPLE DON'T LIKE THE LOOK.
AND I THREW IT OUT AS AN IDEA.
>> Reporter: HIS ADVISORS RULED
IT OUT ON THE KOREAN PRESIDENT.
BUT HE LOVED THE IMAGE OF KIM
JONG-UN TO WALK ACROSS THE BOARD
TO THE SOUTH KOREA PRESIDENT.
AND THINKS IT WOULD BE A MORE
POWERFUL STATEMENT THAN MEETING
IN THE THIRD COUNTRY.
>> I LIKE IT BECAUSE YOU ARE
THERE.
AND IF THINGS WORK OUT THERE IS
A GREAT CELEBRATION TO BE HAD ON
THE SITE AND NOT THE THIRD PARTY
COUNTRY.
AND MORE CONFIDENCE BUILDING
STEPS.
AND THAT IS ON MAY FIFTH.
AND PEYONGCHANG WAS 30 MINUTES
EARLIER.
A SMALL GESTURE AND ARE ONE
SOUTH CORP CORE ATTACHES
SIGNIFICANCE.
>> SUCH MEASURES CARRY OUT HIS
WILL AND WILL TAKE PLACE IN
A FACE PLACE.
>> SOUTH KOREA WILL DISMANTLE
THE LOUD SPEAKER SYSTEM THAT HAS
BRAUFD CASTED OVER NORTH KOREA.
THE SOUTH KOREAN PRESIDENT